[Music]
zeke i'm in captain you were right the
skylight was a window pane i got a
serious interference weird it's some
kind of modal
looks like old code it feels really
familiar drop a pin i'll signal for
backup i'm gonna check it out bugs if
the general finds out we've been fishing
a quick peek can't hurt
did you hear that
[ __ ] i think our signal was chased bugs
this feels like a trap
[Music]
freeze
do not move we will shoot very slowly
raise your hands
[Music]
here we go
hey where are you going
he will warn lieutenant i think we can
handle one little girl
you're wasting your time my men are
bringing her down now
no lieutenant
your men are already dead
this old code keeps crashing rejection's
breaking up switch to audio bugs this is
a direct violation of the general's
but protocols is happening here
something important
oh look we know what happens next
she kicks their ass
so
[Music]
now she makes a call the line was traced
and then and she runs for a life
we know the story
this is how it all began
this is where he began you're thinking
this model is a loop or treadmill
some sort of sequencer involving a
program to do what
i don't
know going to find out all right
why use old code to mirror something new
i don't know
[Music]
if that's supposed to be trinity that's
not what happens
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is bugs you have to get out of here
it's got to be a trap
[Music]
[ __ ]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he'll carry on
because he will
[Music]
killer
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
why did you save me you first who are
you where did you come from okay
my name is bugs
as in bunny
and tech that listens
do you know this is a model
what's a model it's a simulation used to
evolve programs
do you understand that you are
a digital sentients
i know what i am
just like i know my job is to hunt down
and destroy a sentence like you
and yet
here we are
here we are
the other agents don't know about this
room
how'd you find it no one was ever in the
key shop
so i started looking
i really liked the way you
found story of my life
what
hey look i know this trip
holy [ __ ]
this is his apartment
you mean thomas anderson's
i searched everywhere he doesn't exist
he stopped being thomas a long time ago
but maybe you know him by his real name
neo
you do
oh
okay
uh
i can't believe it
after all these years you see most
people
think that neo is dead
but i know he's not
because i've seen him
where
saw something i could explain easily but
[Music]
but the moment he looked at me
i felt something
unlock my mind
you